du rock en bretagne ce week end comme
chaque année c'est saint malo qui est
sur sa route pour sa 20e édition le
festival voit défiler pendant trois
jours de nombreux artistes français ou
étrangers connus ou jeunes talents
viennent benzina gabriel camilla une
armée de festivaliers vient prendre
d'assaut la forteresse du rock
derrière les remparts du fort saint père
ils vont tenir trois jours
programme chargé la fête et puis la
musique assez folles années ils ont
profité en atelier de diane surtout
mettre ces attaques
sinon on est venu un peu
découverte de cette année les
californiennes de dom tom enders
ambiance sixties collants déchirés et
lunettes colorées la route du rock une
pépinière de jeunes talents grâce à une
programmation exigeante
un seul critère comme ça nous touche la
partie au moment où ça nous touche on en
discute ensemble et on se dit est ce que
ce groupe à la place à la route du rock
lui a toujours eu sa place
yann tiersen pour la 20e édition du
festival il interprète les chansons de
son nouvel album avec quinze musiciens
un mélange inattendu de violon
violoncelle et même de musique
électronique
comment j'ai toujours vu la musique
envoûtante quelque chose de super libre
et j'ai toujours rêvé de faire une
musique justement je peux partir dans le
veut en fait
une grosse claque alors j'ai des
frissons encore oui nous a fini là on va
plus écouter autre chose
heureusement il reste 20 me festivaliers
pourrait coûter jusqu'à dimanche soir
voilà